mile 22 is directed by Peter Berg and
stars Mark Wahlberg in their fourth
collaboration together after a lone
survivor Patriots Day and Deepwater
Horizon and this film tells the tale of
an elite top secret tactical command
unit that's trying to get a police
officer out of the country because he
has very specific information and he's
keeping this information at bay until
they get him out of the country and he's
sort of using it as a way to make sure
he can get safely transported to the
United States of America and in so doing
they have to go 22 miles through some
very dangerous territory
I've liked pretty much all of the
collaborations that Peter Berg and Mark
Wahlberg have done so far especially
lone survivor which i think is really
good but something about the way this
film was marketed made it seem like they
were trying to keep a lot from us and
that's usually a good thing but it felt
sort of like a defense and there's
definitely a lot about this film that's
not in any of the trailers for one Mark
Wahlberg's character is very obsessive
he has a rubber band that he keeps her
around his wrist that he pulls and he
hurts himself with it to kind of keep
himself in focus because pain keeps him
focused his character seems to have a
heightened sense of awareness and
thinking he's very clever he kind of
reminded me of a more intense and loud
version of Ben Affleck's character in
the accountant mile 22 struggles from
trying to be a lot of different things
in one movie it's a conventional action
film where a team is trying to get
somebody to safety through a bunch of
gunfire and fight scenes but at the same
time it's really trying to have an
impactful political message that means
something and these two movies don't
really mesh at the end of the film after
like a two-minute scene where a bunch of
information is thrown at us it's kind of
difficult to really understand what the
message behind Peter Burke's film is is
it just an action movie with some fight
scenes and explosions or is this trying
to be something more if it's trying to
be something more which I really do
think it is it's very unclear as to what
they're going for the only thing we
learn about Mark Wahlberg's character is
through narration and files that are
thrown our way during the opening
credits sequence if it wasn't for that
opening credits sequence we wouldn't
know in
thing about his character we learn
everything in those two minutes and
after that we barely figure out anything
else also troubling is that the film
doesn't seem to have a middle it
definitely has a beginning and it
definitely has an end but somewhere
partway through the movie it feels like
the first act and the third act just
collided because there's a setup there's
an opening scene and then we learn a
little bit about what's happening and
then all of a sudden they've got this
guy and they're transporting him and
then the movie is just a big long action
scene and nothing really feels like it
happens in the middle it doesn't really
feel like there's time to breathe and
while I usually actually really like
that in a film here I was hoping for
more I was like what's going on in their
heads were thrown into these action
sequences so quickly with very little
build-up and so it's difficult to care
about what's going on and sometimes we
are asked to give a shit and I just
didn't but by far and I've been saving
this by far the thing about this film
that bugged me the most is Peter Berg's
direction of the action scenes I'm a fan
of Peter Berg I liked his films quite a
bit of them actually here he seems to
have gone back to the mid to late 2000s
and has embraced the shaky hyper
actively edited films of that time
period once again with action scenes
that would be beautiful if he just put
them in a wide or or allowed us to soak
in some moments we have someone as
talented as I kow who ice I believe
that's how you pronounce his name but he
was the lead from the raid films and
here he is and he's also listed as a
fight choreographer in the credits and I
can tell that he's doing amazing things
there's no need for shaky cam and quick
cut editing to mask poor stunt work they
don't show you anything he's doing
because everything is so in-your-face
and and I thought we were past this to
be honest I thought that the people had
made a stand and Hollywood had listened
and then we got films like John wick you
know that understood this or even
despite its faults atomic blonde had
amazing action sequences I thought we
had progressed past this but this film
once again reaches back into the
mid-2000s and says hey
remember when you couldn't tell what the
fuck was going on yeah we like that
right oh you don't well it doesn't
matter we're gonna put it in this movie
I'm a fan of Paul Greengrass and the way
he cuts together quick cut editing and
shaky cam I think he does it with
considerable style and he doesn't use it
in a way to to to like shadow poor stunt
work the action sequences in this film
took all the wrong lessons from Paul
Greengrass his films like the Bourne
films and uses them and in the way that
say like the the last few taken movies
did Olivia or megatons films Columbiana
and that type of action the way it was
cut together and I was sitting the
theater blown away that we got another
big-budget film like this with the
considerable talent on the screen doing
the fight scenes and it's helmed that
way strangely the film also seems rather
oblivious to Mark Wahlberg's celebrity
status because a character in the film
at a very integral moment actually looks
at him and says say hi to your mother
for me and he's like what did you just
say what did you say to me I was sitting
in the theater thinking are they even
aware of the famous Andy Sandberg
Saturday Night Live skit hey dawg how's
it going unlike you've heard that looks
really great so your dog right what's
that all about
okay who's great to meet you say hi to
your mother for me okay did you see the
smle I was just gonna say I am Max Payne
steady and mother for me
it completely took me out of the movie
and there's so many moments like that
where Wahlberg is given these monologues
or our characters say things that are
supposed to be really important and it
just comes off kind of cheesy John
Malkovich is in the film wearing a very
obvious toupee and he's basically like
the guy behind the computer screens who
barks orders at them causing the Edit to
constantly cut to drone shots or or
cameras that are on top of cars it's so
hyperactive that it feels like they
thought everything would be a lot
smarter and sound considerably more
highbrow if it's just cut together
really fast but it doesn't it's just a
barrage of nonsense mile 22 could have
been a really fun action film but it
tries to be so much more it's message is
unclear the action scenes are directed
very poorly and again I must say I am a
fan of Peter Berg and I'm saying this
out of love for his other films this
could have been so much better and it
was very disappointing I'm gonna give
mile 22 a d-plus guys thank you so much
as always for watching look forward to
more reviews very soon coming to you
this weekend as always if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
[Music]
you